[Music]
i'll do the clapping here do the closet
hey
all right welcome back everybody today
new intro delta delta all right sorry
welcome back to off the record where we
talk about
whatever we want and today we've got
kelly milly
yay
i heard you gotta say it fast come on
kelly's a badass cause right after this
she's gonna go film season two of bling
empire yeah last week wait you're on
season two now she's a hustler dude i
thought you guys had many seasons
already
because he doesn't watch a show i didn't
yeah i didn't watch it yet so you still
haven't watched this i watch the clips
okay people i watch the clips he doesn't
have cables i'm not coming back here
anymore oh he's so he's one of those
guys that will wait for the whole thing
to cost he could binge watch the whole
he's a binge watcher yeah you've been
watching for a season because
i love reality tv shows and even my
favorite one that's even better than
bling empire i don't even watch what's
that 90 day fiance oh my gosh
that is better than being empire no
offense to you sorry and then now i'm
really on this other one called um i
think it's called leaving amish oh tlc
has the best shot dude yeah
so much better than bringing up here
really uh
yeah i'm sitting right here i'm sorry
i'm sorry i apologize all right guys
but all of them
after i leave yeah i don't watch the
whole i just watch clips i i have to
admit i haven't seen blinging empire i
will now that's what's up either that or
i'm lying just like joe i didn't know
that there's that many balling asians in
l.a until i watch the show i think you
guys should be on the show like no what
have you like as poor people yes your
house i see your house in vegas have you
been to the beverly center
that's true it's all asian there's so
many rich asians i didn't even know if i
was allowed in there well you're out
there
you're you're a trash asian i've heard i
know but these guys are like no he's
like the guy who goes to nevada he's not
a regular trash agent we got most of
those in like the 66 and right you know
westminster i used to be one of those
guys yeah i'm a nevadan my look you
definitely are still 100
you don't have nevada plates yet pal
you're not in nevada yet i do this isn't
on my car no you don't it's a paper one
i didn't see it paper doesn't count
internally american outwardly you're
like trash asia that's true
yeah you're not you're trash bro the
fade to the buff you're [ __ ] trash
dude
just [ __ ] trash man it's like a asian
refugee
married uh uh monster drinking extreme
sports white guy bro yeah and then they
had a baby yeah i feel personally
attacked
but also that means we're related in
some way oh that's hey i like that
that's pretty funny look at how trash
asian he just pulled out all the
cilantro just like left them down there
i don't eat cilantro either yeah it
tastes like soap right i don't know if
it tastes like soap
but i don't like cilantro and asian food
can i ask you a question have you tasted
soap
have you tasted soap before
yes my parents used to wash my mouth
when i swear really
had that happened
really they did that yeah i thought that
was like only on tv june 1996 i'll never
forget oh yeah
i just said that
should we uh edit that out
my coffee hasn't kicked out yet sorry
guys
i'll keep drinking 296. she's like what
year my uncle told me uh my grandma used
to hang him upside down on a tree and
put hot sauce in his mouth when he would
like say bad words that sounds like a jk
party challenge
but then when i when i look at my
grandma like she's like this five foot
one maybe 80 90 pound little lady and
she looks all sweet with the little
white afro and this is the most
dangerous yes and i would ask her and
i'm like hey grandma is it true what
uncle said about you that when he would
misbehave he would put
hot sauce in his mouth and hang him
upside down he goes well i told him not
to but i'm like oh [ __ ] that's crazy
hardcore yeah cause like you don't
imagine someone that looks cute as [ __ ]
to do crazy [ __ ] like that yeah that's
true
my father-in-law got tied up in a duffel
bag and put and hung from a tree
and and was it like homicide or was it
no no he's alive thank god because he's
my father-in-law but no but he to punish
him for being a bad kid or whatever like
his parents did that hung up in a duffel
bag what do you guys think about like
like uh punishing your kids if they do
wonderful yeah like i wish you guys
would be worse to your kids but they're
not they're like they're just gonna
traumatize them when they grow up well
at least they shut the [ __ ] up
and it works it's worth it i'm happy you
don't have kids right now were you
disappointed a little bit yeah i think
so but not as bad i didn't get like on
upside down yeah like the way that i get
around it is i get like a stick
and then i have taiko hold it and i go
stop hitting yourself hitting yourself
and then that way technically on camera
it's he's the one
it was me
how do you get around i don't know if on
camera works maybe from like a forensics
point of view but like camera doesn't
they can't tell i've heard jeffrey
dahmer didn't kill one person actually
he made them all hit themselves yeah
yeah and there's no fingerprints on the
stick but his yeah except for when you
hand it to him who did it that's when i
use a tweezer
or a chopstick he has rubber gloves yeah
two degrees of separation from the
weapon kelly people are watching right
now they're wondering
if if if you know they haven't seen
blink bling empire all that stuff
sell them season two right now how do
they get in how do they say them like
do you like drama yeah do you like asian
people yeah do you like rich asian
people are you reading the one page
that's literally like the trailer do you
like drama asian people
rich asian people if the answer is yes
watch bling empire all right
so
i like any rich people who's your
favorite rich asian person me
that's gangster dude
that's all right that was a hard
question by the way that was our
question a good answer if you were to
create uh if there was a parallel maybe
maybe for somebody who watches versus
somebody who's on it but like if bling
empire had like characters on it and you
played a character i don't know uh for
example like the x-men or friends or
some other x-men or friends or something
they're one are you one or are you
rachel the same arena or like the
avengers i want to know what role you
play on the show are you a wolverine are
you rachel yeah come on let me know are
you a ross or phoebe or beast you know
carrie branshaw from second city oh [ __ ]
i think you're like a rachel i like
rachel you like rachel what about what
about the x-men question are you gambit
though
are you jubilee she's more like a rogue
oh she's playing rape
what's it next to the wolverine of blue
empire holy [ __ ]
that's huge it's different no well she's
different right because you're you're
you're self-made
on the show and a lot of them they're
like rich kids or heirs right
so then the difference is you
made your money i work hard for my money
did it they took that song i get it i
get it's like cyclops versus wolverine
you are wolverine right i don't know if
cyclops was given anything i really
don't know so he's giving everything
what are you talking about scott summers
is the sport that's [ __ ] yeah he's a
little [ __ ] no one likes that no no one
likes him everybody likes wolverine oh
[ __ ] yeah he's so sick he has pain in
his heart
[Music]
you got trauma that's what it is you got
trump a real person
rich asian pain in your heart i do
are there any choppers in season two
you guys getting your helicopter game up
oh ashley we're thinking about it but no
nothing's filmed yet no yeah
what's the most like unnecessarily rich
lavish thing that happens that you're
allowed to talk about in season two or
just on the show not season two well you
haven't filmed yet haven't you no we're
filming right now we're filming right
now okay fine in season one for somebody
who doesn't know [ __ ] well that was so
one of the sea episodes in season one
was crazy
hi best friend the old lady's name again
anna shea and the [ __ ] yeah her titties
popped out which is crazy hey that's
cool there's titties on the show netflix
we should have mentioned that yeah why
didn't you mention that you're with your
one thing right there yeah there's penis
palm too there's a penis palm pump pump
like a pumpy penis oh a penis pump yeah
i don't know why i did that because i
don't know how it works i don't know how
it works actually never seen a penis
pump yeah it's like a tnt box isn't it
like this or no you never watched the
austin powers movie uh or van wilder but
i've never seen a penis problem
until on the show yeah
but it was someone's birthday and then
they flew to paris for lunch it's my
birthday oh it's your birthday
wow happy birthday wait
so it was they're just like happy
birthday we're going to paris and then
you waited like 12 hours to get there
and then or whatever it's like not your
birthday anymore yeah and you're going
like forward in time
no it is her birthday because it's
backwards and it's backwards in time
also you have to fly back to your
birthday plus it's a reality tv show so
they shot it three months earlier so it
wasn't even really her birthday
there's a lot of planning that goes hey
we we know about filmmaking so yeah
these guys don't film yeah for sure for
sure and you're shooting 12 hour days so
it probably wasn't even the day might
have been night time i don't know you
lost me was that your birthday i
answered the question what yeah
it was my birthday anna decided to
surprise me and took me to paris for uh
for lunch and she shut down the palace
of her side and they gave me a private
tour so that was fun it's like we have
paris we have mr baguette
[Laughter]
is that something she would do if it
even wasn't for the show like that's
just that's that's just that's just anna
so like like so when you guys aren't
filming and you're hanging out she's
just does stuff like that she's just and
stuff like that wow have you ever been i
don't even think she even knows the
camera's really there like she just yeah
she's just like yeah well because our
titties just came out of nowhere yeah
that's pretty crazy easy that's pretty
crazy how often does it happen is that
did the titties come out yeah yeah is it
like a frequent thing i always thought
it happened one time i wasn't even there
titties are only like a one episode of
season thing i understand why it's not
that's in a trailer though for sure how
much do you think all that costs like
her titties no
how much argument should be
how much is all like your birthday
because it was it was just it was more
than you and you and her right it was
like every like everything she at a time
i still with my ex-boyfriend so she flew
me him and then she flew one of my
partners out with her as well and then
yeah today's video is brought to you by
feels okay
cbd isn't about
what you feel it's about what you do not
feel such as stress and anxiety and all
sorts of things that make you go what
the hell is happening in my internal
heart yeah you can't sleep no and you
feel like a time bomb's gonna go off
you're like oh my god help me and these
days especially these i don't know
what's been going on but
i don't know maybe you guys could tell
me what's been going on but there's a
lot of anxiety that's been in the room
lots of stress a lot from places that
are crazy i wish i could just get like a
remote and go peep and turn it all off
but the next best thing is called feels
and i've been having this thing where
like all my life i had a difficulty of
sleeping like insomnia right i remember
yeah but then now i can sleep good
but i get morning anxiety now you get
mornings yeah so like at night i fall
asleep like a baby i'm fine right
but um i'll have these like anxiety
sleep attacks in the morning
like you wake up like like that yeah
like oh my god there's a [ __ ] hyena
cheek like chasing me or something right
so then i gotta get some feels put some
in my [ __ ] tongue listen to some
meditation get my balls stroked a little
bit and then i slowly go back to sleep
that helps out very but very very good
yeah feels is very helpful because if
it's also your first time they also have
an amazing customer service number they
can call they can walk you through the
whole process so that if you're nervous
they can help you with the dose and you
can test it out you just place a few
drops underneath your tongue and it
helps sleepless this anxiety tension
stress all of that helps all of that go
away and they have a really cool
subscription service that helps make
self-care really easy and you get a
discount on it so if you want to check
this out go to feels.com
off the record that's f e a l s dot com
off the record to get 50 off your first
order plus free shipping that's 50 off
your first order go to feels.com off the
record i feel it
i feel it too and then the whole palace
of verse how do you even rent
or close it down like yeah you can't
even pay for that it's connections yeah
can you be honest did you take a [ __ ] in
the palace of versailles i did not
because the toilet's looking like it
would have been the concept oh it's like
a hole
you know oh it is yeah i already ripped
one big one
i took a piss at marie antoinette's
house in the back
i took a dump it had freaks
[Laughter]
helen keller or something it's the only
one that was available to my brain still
there it's still there actually
there's a house in the back
for his house
if hers for his favorite hoe and then
you could you could take a bike right
there and it's like a little she has her
own area yeah for your tits no marie
antoinette is is uh the king louie's
favorite girlfriend yeah yeah and she
had her own house since you've seen all
kinds of ball and [ __ ] like what
has to happen or what has recently
happened that impresses you still that
you're like oh [ __ ] that's pretty
[ __ ] crazy i [ __ ] up this officer
yeah
you gotta go down you can't go i've
already gone out this way
i don't know how do people live in here
well i went to greece recently yeah with
friends that was awesome we uh yeah
that's we're in greece
about wearing creatures
with private they're a jet just swedex
and he had a whole place the whole plane
was soundproofed so that was pretty cool
the plane was soundproof yeah i never
did an international private flight well
i never did a private domestic flight
but then is that a is that like are you
on a big 737 or whatever but like i
don't i think it's like 747 on one of
those but it was a it's not it's a
commercial flight that's normally i
think it fits about 150 people
and then they completely redid it can
you walk me through the whole because
i'm pretty sure you you probably don't
go to tsa either right no can you walk
me through the process of how a rich
person gets the grace yeah bro like tell
us tell us this i don't know there's an
elevator
someone pick you up and put you in a
limo to go to the you pull up you roll
down the window you flip off everyone
outside first that's why i should do an
accident
a rickshaw comes in that's golden yeah
pulls you over to the plane no but how
does it start like do you well you just
you pull up you get out you get on a
plane and you take off that's it no
you're missing details bro
or do you walk through tsa or you punch
them in the stomach yeah
sorry sir
right away you just you're just walking
making a rain the whole time
are there poor people outside and then
you there's not raining so you take a
bucket of water and just throw it once
you drive by
you want to travel with me i would love
it actually it'll be so crazy do all
these obnoxious things i'm an ideas guy
yeah perfect perfect can i travel with
you yeah you can travel too
terrification
you can be the one that carries me yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah
we should have a chair
can we just carry her like a freaking
egyptian princess i meant for that i'll
do anything to get past tsa i feel like
i hate you i know we'll do we'll do
almost anything but joe will never watch
bling empire
i'll watch it okay i i'll i promise i'll
watch you probably get lost in my life i
know but i watched the clips what clips
on instagram instagram and youtube give
up give him an episode to start with in
season one this guy will carry you on a
chair but he won't watch your show
so where do you start the beginning no
no no your favorite episode
do you want to see a live child birth oh
huh yeah washable empire okay you know
how to work the room
i know my audience
she knew i was going to say yes yeah i
mean i've seen joey's the crazy [ __ ] he
does yeah i'm like okay well that makes
sense do you know what a mouth massage
is it sounds really nice watch bling on
okay
she's good at that line
you got me wait this one yeah is it
getting your mouth massage or giving a
massage with your mouth well i gotta
watch good
i think you're even supposed to dive
into it i think it's like a hot topic
watch blind um
that's so inside your mouth with your
penis
like that oh i don't know i don't think
we were going there
let's go
all i know the main ingredients right
now is a bunch of money there's like
tits in what episode there's a penis
pump there's a mouth massager it's
getting pretty exciting for me yeah yeah
that's pretty much what's gonna seal the
deal for you though anything like what's
gonna be the nail in the coffin for you
to be all of those have to be in in
episode one after that i'm for sure
watching episode two a lot happens i
mean it's like baller people but they
still got their problems and stuff too
no spoiler alert bro yeah wow dude but
the numbers that my um wealthy friends
throw out it's pretty hilarious like
we're having lunch with um my friend out
in hawaii coincidentally he was out
there buying a house in uh kahala it's
this really nice area and then um he was
like yeah you know
everything's so expensive now they're
trying to charge me 12 million and i'm
like i'm not paying more than eight and
me and david are like looking at each
other like yeah you tell them man don't
don't don't don't don't pay 12 million
man that's crazy
eight million oh come on that's you
can't pay more than that and i'm like
this [ __ ] dude man that's a lot of
money man
yeah but the numbers are just crazy that
a lot of money yeah that sounds kind of
poor i think yeah yeah yeah broke boy
come for the bill he's like we're gonna
do split four wins
[Laughter]
no he goes to the bathroom he's like
i'll be back yeah have you have you seen
rich people do that oh there's a couple
friends
not gonna say names not in our show not
on our show but like when you know when
the bills come without fight for the
bill there's a couple people every
single time they go to the bathroom
every single time they're wealthy though
just say sounds that rhymed with their
name
it's like you know
wing
chun
[Laughter]
the only way i've ever beaten my
father-in-law to the bill was going to
the bathroom and telling the waiter to
give me the bill that's a good that's a
good move so i i do that yeah where as
soon as you come in you hand it to you
hand your card to them yep right away
huh that's the move because otherwise
that man would [ __ ] be i pulled the
shady before i gotta admit it you know
sometimes when uh
you wanna pay your respect you know and
you wanna be honorable but at the same
time you know you're not you know you're
not the
one gotta do
i'm reaching for the wallet you gotta
make a scene out of it you know what i
mean when you make a scene out of it
then it's just like a test of might and
then you always just have to lose right
at the last second i'm really good with
that not non-crypto you actually really
are good at losing really a lot of money
i've seen that yeah go ahead and smile a
little bigger you can you teach me
it's easy to lose money she's like i
have too much i i just keep it yeah
you spend time with me guarantee you're
going to lose money perfect
i actually i went through all of his
accounts with him yesterday and i've
never laughed so hard i'm not
it was i feel horrible about it but even
i mean nick knows i was laughing my ass
off this morning about this [ __ ]
dude
his laugh just made me laugh i just
couldn't i couldn't making money is just
as much of a skill as losing money yeah
then i'm skillful you're very skilled
and losing people sleep on it it's a
game dude it's a different type of game
pretty impressive what if you try even
investing
opposite your instincts
that's literally what happened he told
me he's like i'm gonna hold off on
buying this one and then it just jumped
up like 15 this morning yeah
i did i did opposite what what i would
have done yeah and then it went the
other way i think
i think i'm just you know when you got
like a lucky rabbit's foot like whatever
the unlucky version
you should read me
you should like genuinely like a fortune
tell you should ask me what i think and
i should give you i'm gonna text you
from now on for real should i buy today
yes no
don't say should i about to be like hey
you're gonna buy today ask me what i'm
gonna be excited about it sell it
and if he wants to buy it
you're doomed dude yeah you're doomed oh
[ __ ] wait wait a little bit
are you guys gonna give him a percentage
of your winning
no
he's gotta lose i'm your man your agent
now i got you i got you 20 i already
gave him a pretty sick come up actually
so that's fine i think he could take all
of our losses this is only one it's it's
only move that he didn't lose on
actually well you gave me a tip last
time
just let you know i'm down just letting
you know we're all they gave you that
tip they were buying bitcoin with you it
wasn't me well we all bought one
we all lost together but i also said you
gotta wait 10 years buy it and don't
look out for 10 years yeah i was the
only one who didn't buy bitcoin last
time if you were he was in the bathroom
i remember that oh he's that guy he goes
to the bathroom while everybody's buying
bitcoin
10 years 10 years
what's going to be my average though
it's a long time it's probably gonna be
like 150 or 300
per bitcoin in 10 years oh bro shooting
that that's what three times
that's pretty good ten years yeah and
she's not happy with those numbers for
ten years i'd be dead by dead
i don't have time for that i need fast
money that's what i'm saying 10 years
yeah i could be dead by then too yeah in
10 years
you my lifestyle yeah believable not you
not you you're going places you're
careful yeah you might lose a lot but
you didn't lose in the woman that you
have bringing me down bringing me up
it's really emotional because
[Music]
you